[Music]
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
ten times
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
[Music]
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
[Music]
elements of bathrooms god bless
the united states thank you very much
elephants and bathrooms
mangoes my bags are mangoes
[Music]
i love mangoes too nine
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes like
three by seeds
that's it
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
going
the wisconsin crowd identifying with the
mangoes
forcefully
[Music]
highway robbery is what you're doing
wow well welcome everybody it is the
first presentation of the january 6th
committee hearings it is an incredible
evening and we are standing by 30
minutes from now the hearings will start
many making a big deal out of this while
others downplaying it and saying
nothing to see here
please disperse
anybody get that one we'll go to that
actually in a little bit
uh what a situation there were questions
people wrote to me with tears in their
eyes and they said sir
you had a baby
are you going to be here for the stream
i am on paternity leave but here i am
um the paternity leave isn't changing
i'm going to talk about that a little
bit later thank you to everybody who
sent congratulations but i'm not going
to miss this i mean this we have to see
but i am going to
i am going to talk in a little bit about
the paternity leave and i i believe
about one percent of the people in the
audience
are not going to like what i have to say
about it because they are the one
percent that i am going to absolutely
destroy
and tell never to watch my show again
david sir what are you talking about
just stand by
okay just stand by we're gonna get to
that
uh okay where to even start
alex wood
sends some thanks
industry says i'm gonna need some
diapers i don't know if you mean the
baby will need diapers
or if you mean we're going to need
diapers because of what is going to be
presented tonight it could be either
mazel tov david many positive wishes for
you and pac mini wow thank you chakaseki
by the way uh dr chakaseki checking in
we love that
many medical specialties represented
among the audience we have uh it's i
honestly
i believe that neurology
and radiology are the two most
represented medical specialties
in our audience
actually and pathologists as well
now pathologists is interesting because
some of them are mds
i have a friend who's a pathologist who
actually
is a biology phd
and an md
sort of like as an add-on it's quite an
interesting specialty but anyway that's
not what we're talking about here thank
you chakaseki
congrats oh boy we're going to keep
going now that your baby is under
abiden's regime congratulations of
course
david how can i convince my fox news
brainwashed father that the hearings
aren't just liberal bs and he should
watch i don't know that in the 28
minutes we have left
you can do that
unfortunately even i'm not that uh that
good
david search should twitter unban trump
tonight only so he can rage tweet and
incriminate himself further well
actually tomorrow's guest host luke
beasley
is going to show us some of donald
trump's um truth essential
posts about these hearings hold on do i
have my truth truth
president donald j trump
virtue
cycling advising lawmakers
if you care about law and auto you're
going to see some citizens
coming americans of all walks of life
rose up yes the americans from lice are
people we need to be very very careful
with
okay
excuse me okay uh no com i mean uh
twitter can decide what to do
okay let's look at some things guys we
have limited time until this begins
let's see
first and foremost marjorie taylor green
in another
febrile diatribe on the floor of the
house today
said that she's been fragrantly violated
listen to this and why their due process
rights are being so fragrantly and
horrifically violated i don't know
exactly who
smelt it or or who dealt it
but that is something that you've got to
look at very very strongly um that that
is uh i i marjorie i can smell you from
here okay my friend so that's a very
very powerful indictment on odors and
things like that
um here so aaron rupar actually uh fox
news freddie dismissed it they're tuning
up and that's why the american people
have already dismissed it they're tuning
out they're gonna flip the channel
tonight on prime time tv to channels
that aren't showing it because they
don't trust it to begin with it's
awesome
nobody's gonna watch tonight guys i mean
okay like i've been streaming five
minutes
and there's already six thousand people
watching across our various platforms
but nobody's interested in this it
reminded me of this classic scene from
one of my absolutely favorite movies
[Applause]
nothing to see here please
yep okay so the great uh the great
leslie nielsen there
here is this is i i like how patriot
takes calls this a particularly low move
like the standards are already really
low for gates gates said jamie raskin
friend of the show guys friend of the
show
okay i've been public i think jamie
raskin's great he's on this committee i
think he's fantastic
matt gates attacked jamie raskin saying
he shouldn't be on the committee
because
he's unable to do his job because his
son died by suicide
can you think of sicker people than
these two what i worry about with raskin
in all seriousness you know
when people
encounter
trauma they often associate a lot of the
other things around that trauma with it
even if they don't right that's guys
jamie raskin thinks that the
insurrection was wrong
because he's
transposing and projecting the death of
his son
onto the capitol rioters who were really
antrifa
could these people be any sicker
naturally or or even rationally
associated maybe so and what i what uh
matt gates p h d e d d l m h c i worry
about for
the congress and for for uh jamie raskin
you know no one whatever he's just
concerned guys it's just he's just very
worried about raskin i want to lose a
child particularly to suicide of course
as a
our hearts go out to him but yeah i
think that he takes that trauma and he
associates it now with his work in the
congress right to such such an
interwoven way that he's unable to kind
of this is the modern definition of
sophistry right i mean it's uh
it it's it's
man i it's so sick i'm not even gonna
play the rest of it okay it's that it's
that vial so we looked at this we looked
at this
um
man those people are those people are
really really sick by the way
we i it's hard to think of someone
better to be on this committee than
jamie raskin like i i'm having i'm
having trouble thinking of who who would
i prefer on this committee over jamie
raskin
anyone who has experienced a bad thing
can't be trusted to do anything
by the way
matt gates under multiple criminal
investigations for things up to and
including sex crimes
but the stress of that no he's very well
placed to comment on everything
absolutely
these people are truly sick truly truly
sick people
okay other super chats coming in
congratulations david glad you're here
for this theme i love watching history
happen with your commentary glad to have
you here cyrus or ceruse
beautiful 50 super chat from bryson hall
by little david junior some diapers well
in the jewish faith we don't do junior
sir but i appreciate it the baby is
blessed to have you as a father
i appreciate that very much
um yeah i'm gonna need to get some
diapers i figure you need what like
a couple diapers a week or something
like that
you can't possibly need that many can
any parents can can you guys tell me
what you
like a pack of 12 must get you through a
month or two right
nobody knows huh weird anyway i have six
i figure that'll get me through a few
weeks and then we can look for more
congrats on the baby mango obama pacman
thank you adam
pakman is on paternity leave producer
pat is on pat ernity leave
congratulations even the doctor was like
sir yeah they
they really were
the daddy pacman show thank you very
much all right in all seriousness
welcome everybody we i don't even know
what we're going to see tonight but i
expect it to be absolutely bonkers
absolutely bonkers
um
[Music]
congratulations to you and your fiance
david glad the baby will go grow up with
critical thinking
thank you
gates thinks he comes off as a shrewd
and astute observer it's hilarious and
dangerous at the same time it's more
dangerous i would say than anything else
i would
a couple other things to play for you
here are our friends over at the good
liars
asking on since we have these hearings
starting asking someone a question who
believes antifa did the riots let's
listen that should be fascinating how do
you all feel about the events of january
6th
uh a lot of that was antifa
[Laughter]
oh man it's a parody of itself
really um yes why why would antifa
interrupt the certification of an
election in which their candidate
won wouldn't they want him to be
certified fair fair question i mean
that's a that's fair
um
it just they
just want to disrupt
in any way possible right do you think
do you think antifa wanted him to be
president i guess is what i'm asking yes
yeah
so why would they interrupt the
certification of the vote on january 6th
is if you is just like
if you have a
yeah it
doesn't make sense right
like why would they would do that
yeah um
i believe that you you just witnessed
what happens when your brain turns to
mayonnaise
it happened in real time
this is a glitch you know
we've seen glitches before right
no more drachma
jp right jd mandel a rhino named mitt
romney obama we know glitches right we
know five second glitches
this is the sound i'm gonna play listen
extremely carefully this is the sound of
a brain turning to
mayonnaise
yeah
it
doesn't make sense right
like why would they would do that
well
how do you all feel about the events oh
wait a sec oh my god is the guy holding
a mcdonald's bag
oh god that is that
i would almost say this must be an actor
if that's a mcdonald's bag
i can't tell
i think it's a greasy mcdonald's bag
it's too it's too perfect it's arby's
oh my god that is it's almost
too good where if you brought this to
her if you brought this to jerry
bruckheimer he'd go
this is too out there even for me it's
too on the nose man wow
shocking shocking stuff
uh okay
jesse lee peterson oh yeah here's our
friend jessie lee peterson uh you guys
know him right
yeah okay he had a new view on white
supremacy i guess i used to think that
when they used that word white supremacy
it was a negative word but now i realize
what they're thinking is that
and it's true by the way
that that white
men are smarter than them
superior to them and and instead of
learning
hey how did you become so superior they
want to destroy so that they won't be
reminded how dumb they are and right so
they're dominant everybody this is even
making white supremacists blush
and everything down rather than coming
up to the level of white supremacy yeah
um
god
really really shocking shocking sick
stuff uh so there's the latest from
jessie lee peterson all right other
super chats coming in let's see what
else we've got seeing that person's
whole world crumble is amazing please
sir can i have some more yeah
david congrats on being a dad will potty
training involve elements of bathrooms
and flushing 15 times i actually have
hired a uh they call them um it's a
specialty plumber
and i said to the plumber listen um
[Music]
whatever is the widest pipe and the
highest water pressure that you can
legally or illegally just don't even
tell me let's not even discuss the
legality don't pull any permits just
whatever
what's the most you can do for me here
in turn because i don't want to be
flushing 10 or 15 times
and the plumber said to me with tears in
his eyes he said sir i'm going to set
you up for what would handle an elephant
and i said beautiful install it do it
i'm going to need that do it right now
mazeltov for the new edition the world
needs more pacman's thank you very much
i really appreciate that
uh all right
let's go okay listen i'm gonna address
something now and this is gonna be
uncomfortable for some people okay
denver mccarthy says while you're on
leave i'm having to instead watch sam
cedar what a nightmare denver you know i
love you and this this just reminds me
this is not about you uh but you you
reminded me of this okay
um i am
really bummed out
really bummed out by some messages that
i received in the last 72 hours okay
as many of you might know
you don't know
when a baby is going to show up
the baby you know you've got like a
month range
okay now i know people are already
getting defensive in the chat okay just
just listen okay because this is
actually a serious thing
in the last 72 hours
we've been running some like classic or
themed episodes where we like compiled a
bunch of our stuff about like the 22
elections or whatever we ran a bunch of
this stuff
in the last 72 hours i got some of the
most
horrible messages
from
supposed supporters of the show and
progressives
saying stuff like david
i'm cancelling my membership because
you're running repeats like i get it
you're on paternity leave
but i'm not paying for this
i'll consider re-subscribing when you
get back
okay messages like
why are you
uh running repeats right now
when are you coming back guys it's it's
been it's been you know it's been a few
days
okay um and there's two things about
there's three things about this that i
think are really really horrible okay
number one first and foremost
um
aren't we progressives
like
don't we believe in
paid paternity leave
i'm self-employed you guys realize that
right like i don't have some other job
this is more than a full-time job so i'm
not saying you have to fund my paternity
leave but what i'm saying is if we're
progressives
and we say there should be paternity
leave where do you think the money comes
from when you're self-employed now if
you don't like the show by by all means
okay but
this is a little bit weird for
progressives to be doing and saying so
that is genuinely disappointing
um now on the other hand there's another
aspect to this which is the people
emailing me
about how they've unsubscribed not not
canceled memberships people who don't
pay people who who already don't pay
right 99.5 percent of our audience or
don't pay and that's fine we love you
anyway the people who don't pay wrote to
me and said i'm that's it i'm done
repeats cancelled
i can't take this i i was waiting for
the show
you're telling me how much the show
means to you
you're saying david i count on the hour
we spend together every day so much
that i'm furious that you're not doing
new shows right now i'm canceling hey if
it's worth that much to you
i don't know maybe you could support the
show
right like there's a cup
this is terrible i'm feel so mad it's
just a terrible thing oh well it sounds
like the show means something to you
then it does
so anyway this is like one percent of
the messages i've gotten but really
depressing stuff
really depressing stuff both because
and this is why the right i don't want
to make this about everybody
the right goes oh
listen do i the people who fund charlie
kirk okay you think they're watching
that stupid show
where he sits with his enormous face
and and and uh says
they don't watch that crap
they just fund it because they go this
guy's fighting for the right stuff i
don't care what he does paternity leave
hungover drinking i don't care they just
go we gotta fund this thing because this
is important to us okay
and then the progressives go david
you're out for some you know period of
time uh and it was like all of a sudden
you're gone i'm pulling my membership
guys
we're not we're just not gonna
win we're not gonna win okay
so anyway that that's my rant i'm done
with it
um appreciate everybody who's here
and uh we do by the way listen if you
wanna sign up and support what we're
doing we have the code indict now by the
way
the plan is not repeats tomorrow the
show is going to be hosted by the great
luke beasley
monday producer pat is going to be
hosting the show and then i'll have news
about what's forthcoming and i'm going
to be i'm going to be around guys i love
doing this okay so i'm going to be
around
but um yeah guys come on come on
by the way some people also seem to
think if you've got a yearly membership
what's the point of cancelling and then
signing up like you'll just end up
paying twice it's very very silly all
right how much sleep did i get last
night six hours per my um
per my
you know the thing six hours last night
uh coupon code today is indict i i'm not
i refuse to explain why the code is
indict it should be obvious to everybody
why today
the coupon code is indict you can use
the coupon code at joinpakman.com okay i
recommend yearly you just pop in there
very very simple coupon code you type in
indict boom
absolutely crazy okay
absolutely crazy discount i would love
for people to use this coupon code and
um it's it's all it's all happening all
right now as we wait oh my god super
chats
look at this 200 super chat from sassy
funds for paternity leave sassy thank
you that's that's incredible
thank you so much that was a crowder
reference sir mazel tov take all the
time you need thank you denver
david i'm from britain and i'm furious
you think an american deserves a single
second of paternity leave disgusting i
know right
uh okay a lot of messages to offset the
negative karma yeah it was a it was bad
juju i like i don't even believe in
karma but it just it was it was bad juju
all right
i always listen to you on my drive from
work thank you i appreciate that
congratulations thanks duane
here's five bucks that's enough for
diapers for the year yeah thank you i
appreciate that's more than enough
more than enough
um thanks lg for the super chat okay in
all seriousness though let me let's
before this starts because this is going
to be bonkers let me let me do some
thank yous
a whole bunch of people signed up via tv
and tv
those people are oh i can't even name
these people there's so many
uh sweet thang cortina danish joint jay
tandaway jen here kind af small fuzzy
moss might just have to count him seven
eight 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21
nug donated 5 is 26 green man no donated
5 that's 31
32 33 34 35 36 37
wow
thank you to the 37
twitch subscribers as we stand by
guitar goddess dumping in 10 more puts
us at 47 and then let me thank people
signing up on the website
mark gettman jr is a new member david
cox
juan gifting one
uh kevin gouldy with a gift
elizabeth smith signed up benjamin minga
elizabeth smith donating todd kroger
luke brown
george bernard
lee
evan
andre delez
hillary lee
uh very much appreciate that that puts
us at 56 we are eight minutes from this
this is a major major event
super chats are dumping in tristan is
inspired that i had a child wow thank
you tristan
love the show here is to shove it to the
cruel messages you receive from one dad
to another thank you brian appreciate
that
congrats enjoy the leave thanks jay
sorry about the individuals desperate to
be upset about something forget them
congratulations thank you becca rebecca
sorry
felicidades
espanol
okay great question yes i will be
speaking only spanish to the baby so
like for example if i had to report to
the baby about the shooting in texas
instead of saying to the baby the
shooting was in youvaldi or yuval day or
anything i would say there was a
shooting in ubalde
boom and then we're done
uh it's going to be going to be pretty
serious oh magaya uh paternity funds
once you so convert and subtract youtube
you should see a hundred bucks thank you
i appreciate that
uh a lot of congrats coming in i
appreciate that everybody
chris bonucci with a producer lewis
reference con congrats david if i had a
kid i'd probably love the kid yes this
is a famous old school reference former
producer lewis during a discussion more
than a decade ago on the show
said
if i accidentally had a kid
that he would probably love the kid
which is which was really a seminal
moment in the david pakman show
six hours in of sleep in a row or broken
up it was six hours over
an eight-hour period
over an eight-hour period
um
dropping some banhammers a lot of
conspiracy stuff in the chat
it's just all you're just it's done
everybody's going away
congrats david thank you
thrilled to hear about it check out the
snoo oh i've got us new
i've got us new
you know i'm actually genuinely worried
i don't know if people have heard of
this device called the snoo
i'll show you a picture of it
it's a pretty it's a pretty weaponized
piece of equipment you i think some
people will know where i'm going with
this because of mike pillow's lawsuit
against all machines you guys know about
this right this is the device
um it's a bassinet
that has motion it has elements of
motion and it senses when the baby is
acting up and i was lucky lucky enough
to get one at a discount even bigger
than my membership discounts from a
friend
uh but you guys know that the all
machines may be shut down we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines i saw i found this thing for
pennies on the dollar and now i'm
worried it's going to be wrapped up in
legal hell for years because of the
lawsuit against all machines it's it's
absolutely crazy
uh yeah i'm losing all of my machines
it's it's shocking someone actually
wrote to me something pretty funny about
the whole lawsuit against all machines
thing
tommy wrote to me and said um
this is so funny people write to me the
funniest stuff tommy said david my dad
owns a wood shop and he just received a
letter from lindell's lawyers about the
class action lawsuit they're attempting
to shut down his lathe i'm worried
they're going to be coming for his table
saw sanders drill press and other
machines yeah no that lawsuit is a big
big deal mexico
sorry hold on we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines yep
welcome to the machine the album is
completely done as well uh
it's completely it's completely messed
up
okay let me thank a few other people jug
dealer and bob's burgers rich bird
nation fearsighted high goal sheldon
black frystar
all signing up via twitch prime that's
63.
uh m santali just dumped in 10 more
memberships also thanks to stumpy noob
the life and times of charles s french
slingblade and up in flames
puts us at 78. guys we may be at 100
before this insanity even starts
because look at what's happening on the
website
hold on a second eric lavonne
jenny boyle
hillary lee
kelly lightfoot douglas robinson
saucy cupelian
keith rodri
chris crosati
bobby what toeics is that my friend
bobby bobby is that you is that like the
bobby with toets
that's not a common name that's got to
be my buddy bobby
uh jeremy dunham
emilio leslie
rachel mast
neil
another one from hillary bryce arnold
with a membership
lee with another gift tom burns
guys we might be at 100 already desiree
de long
brian ternuzio
that's 18. lee with another gift
daniel schweigler davis devo de barton
kevin snow i can't even keep up with the
memberships tia ayaroa
tyler smith
samantha grimm
that is 22. oh that puts us at a hundred
that is a shocking number right at the
stroke of 8 p.m almost yeah this is
starting momentarily
love the show take your paternity leave
and hurry back george bradford thanks
george i really appreciate that folks if
you're just joining us we are almost at
the stroke of 8 p.m in the east 5 p.m in
the west we have 10 000 people watching
across all of our platforms it is an
incredible day
skittle stew just dumped in another 10
subscriptions via twitch prime we were
told to expect
mind-blowing content at these hearings
this is only the first of i believe it's
either four or six
it starts in one minute
it is going to be
i mean listen
if it ends up being a bust
i'll tell you i think this is a bust
okay i mean i'll tell you what i think i
don't
i don't care if it's a bust it's a bust
um
it's one let me actually i have these
all on my schedule let me see exactly
how many
hearings this is so there's tonight
next week there are hearings on monday
wednesday and thursday at 10 a.m
it is six then it's the following week
tuesday 10 a.m and then the final one
will be another wait is it another prime
time no thursday the 23rd is the sixth
session that will be in prime time
this is we are moments away
and there are rumors that there will be
video testimony from ivanka and jared
kushner
um
jamie raskin told us when i asked him do
you think your your colleagues are going
to prison or will be indicted
he said
he didn't comment he didn't comment
let's just leave it there
okay
uh let's see what else we've got
congrats from sarai i appreciate that
sir please use these funds to start a
properly balanced portfolio for the
little one i recommend low-cost index
funds what else is there guys is there
anything other than low-cost index funds
for a 529
of course not that's what you want you
want
the uh you want those low cost
if you're paying more than five basis
points
i don't know what to tell you
um
congrats from janine
congrats from jp oh hold on a second
that i have to that i have to deal with
we've endorsed jp right j.d mandel thank
you jd mandel with the big uh
with the big support i very much
appreciate that and here they come let's
listen
there is liz cheney
a rhino a rhino named mitt romney
yep that
is maybe the best uh the best
sound in politics i've ever heard
leo dutilie with a new membership gordon
hall signing up desiree winters wendy
adair welcome everybody guys come on in
everybody's welcome here no matter your
creed
height
favorite movies even if you like arby's
like the people from earlier everybody's
welcome here
all right
our friend jamie raskin there jamie by
the way jamie raskin was
thrilled
with our conversation
okay
sir mike the select committee to
investigate the january 6th attack
on the united states capitol will be in
order
without objection the chair is
authorized to declare the committee
in recess at any point
oh god the house
deposition authority regulation 10
the chair announces the committee's
approval to release the deposition
material presented during tonight's
hearing
thanks to everyone watching tonight for
sharing part of your evening
to learn the facts and causes of the
events leading up to
and including the violent attack on
january 6
our democracy electoral system and
country
i'm benny thompson chairman of the
january 6th
2021 committee
i was born raised and still live in
bolton mississippi
a town with a population of 521
which is midway between jackson and
vicksburg mississippi
and the mississippi river all right i'm
from a part of the country where people
justify the actions of slavery
the ku klux klan and lynching cool i'm
reminded of that dark history as i hear
voices today
try and justify the actions of the
insurrectionists on january 6 20 21.
over the next few weeks
hopefully you will get to know
the other members my colleagues up here
and me
we represent a diversity of communities
from all over the united states rural
areas and cities
east coast west coast and the heartland
all of us have one thing in common
we swore the same oath
that same oath that all members of
congress take upon taking office and
afterwards every two years if they are
reelected
we swore an oath to defend the
constitution
against all enemies foreign
and domestic
the words of the current oath taken by
all of us
that nearly every united states
government employee takes have their
roots in the civil war throughout our
history the united states has fought
against foreign enemies to preserve our
democracy electoral system and country
when the united states capital was
stormed and burned in 1814
foreign enemies were responsible
after war
in 1862 when american citizens had taken
up arms against this country
congress adopted a new oath to help make
sure no person who had supported the
rebellion could hold a position abroad
trust
therefore
congresspersons and united states
federal government employees were
required for the first time to swear an
oath to defend the constitution
against all enemies
foreign and domestic
that oath was put to test on january 6
2021.
the police officers who held the line
that day
honored their oath
many came out of that day
blooded and broken
they still bear those wounds visible and
invisible
they did their duty
they repelled the mob and ended the
occupation of the capital
they defended the constitution against
domestic enemies
so that congress could return
uphold our own oath
and count your votes to ensure the
transfer of power
just as we've done for hundreds of years
but unlike in 1814
it was domestic enemies of the
constitution
stormed the capital and occupied the
who sought to throt the will of the
people
to stop the transfer of power
and so they did so at the encouragement
of the president of the united states
the president of the united states
trying to stop the transfer of power
a precedent that had stood for 220 years
even as our democracy had faced its most
difficult tests
thinking back again to the civil war
in the summer of 1864
the president of the united states
believed he we would be
doomed to bid his bid for reelection
he believed his opponent
general george mcclellan
would wave the white flag when it came
to preserving the union
but even with that grim fate hanging in
the balance
president lincoln was ready to accept
the will of the voters
come what may
he made a quiet pledge
he wrote down the words
this morning
as for some days past
it seems exceedingly probable
that this administration will not be
reelected
then it will be my duty
to so cooperate with the
president-elect it will be my duty
lincoln sealed that memo and asked his
cabinet secretaries to sign it sight
unseen
he asked them to make the same
commitment he did to accept defeat
if indeed defeat was the will of the
people
to uphold the rule of law
to do whatever president who came before
him did
and whatever president who followed him
would do
until donald trump
donald trump lost the presidential
election true 2020.
the american people voted him out of
office it was not because of a rigged
system
it was not because of voter fraud
don't believe me
hear what his former attorney general
had to say about it
i warn those who watching
that this connect contains strong
language perfect
know just what i've i've been i've had i
had three discussions with the president
that i can recall one was on november
23rd oh look at this it was on december
first and one was on december 14th that
has been through
sort of the give and take of those
discussions and in that context i made
it clear i did not agree with
the idea of saying the election was
stolen and putting out this stuff which
i told the president was okay
and uh
you know i didn't want to be a part of
it and that's one of the reasons that
went into me deciding to leave when i
did i so he admits that observed uh i
think it was on december 1st that you
know how can we you can't live in a
world where where the incumbent
administration stays in power based on
its view
unsupported by specific evidence
that the election that there was fraud
in the election look at this
look
on election day 2020 he was the attorney
general of the united states
the top law enforcement official in the
country
telling the president exactly what he
thought about claims of a stolen
election
donald trump had his days in court to
challenge the results
he was within his rights to seek those
judgment
in the united states
law-abiding citizens have those tools
for pursuing justice
he lost in the courts just as he did at
the ballot box
and in this country
that's the end of the line
but for donald trump
that was only the beginning of what
became a sprawling multi-step conspiracy
aimed at overturning the presidential
election
aimed at throwing out the votes of
millions of americans your votes
your voice in our democracy and
replacing the will of the american
people with his will to remain in power
after his turn ended
donald trump was at the center of this
conspiracy
and ultimately donald trump the
president of the united states
spurred a mob of domestic enemies of the
constitution
to march down the capitol and subvert
american democracy
any legal jargon you hear about
seditious conspiracy
obstruction of an official proceeding
conspiracy to defraud the united states
boils down to this
january 6 was the culmination of an
attempted coup
a brazen attempt
as one riot to put it
shortly after january 6 to overthrow the
government
the violence was no accident
it represents
senate trump's last stand
most desperate chance to halt the
transfer of power
now you may hear those words and think
this is just another political attack on
donald trump
by people who don't like him
that's not the case
my colleagues and i all wanted an
outside independent commission
to investigate january 6
similar to what we had
after 9 11.
but after first agreeing to the idea
donald trump's allies in congress
correct put a stop to it yep apparently
they don't want january 6 investigated
at all of course
and in the last 17 months many of those
same people have tried to whitewash what
happened on january 6th correct to
rewrite history
call it a tourist visit
label it legitimate political discourse
donald trump and his followers have
adopted the words of the songwriter
do you believe me
or your lying eyes
we can't sweep what happened under the
rug
the american people deserve answers
so i come before you
this evening not as a democrat but as an
american who swore an oath to defend the
constitution
the constitution doesn't protect just
democrats or just republicans
it protects all of us
we the people
and this scheme was an attempt to
undermine the will of the people
so tonight
and over the next few weeks
we're going to remind you of the reality
of what happened that day
but our work
must do much more than just look
backwards
because of our democracy remains in
danger the conspiracy to thought the
will of the people is not over
there are those in this audience who
thirst for power but have no love or
respect for what makes america great
devotion to the constitution
allegiance to the rule of law
our shared journey to build a more
union
january 6th and the lies that led
to insurrection have put two and a half
centuries of constitutional democracy at
risk
the world is watching what we do here
america has long been expected to be a
shining city on the hill
a beacon of hope and freedom
a model for others when we are at our
best
how can we play that role when our house
is in such disorder
we must confront the truth with candor
resolve and determination
we need to show that we are worthy of
the gifts that are the birthright of
every american
that begins here and it begins now
with a true accounting of what happened
and what led to the attack on our
constitution and our democracy in this
moment
when the dangers of our constitution and
our democracy loom large nothing could
be more important
working alongside the public servants on
this dias has been one of the greatest
honors of my time in congress
it's been a particular privilege to
count as a partner in this effort
and to count as a friend
the gentlewoman from wyoming ms cheney
uh-oh she's a patriot
a public found courage of devotion to
her oath and the constitution triggered
my pleasure to recognize ms cheney for
her opening statement republicans are
about thank you very much mr chairman
and let me echo uh those words about the
importance of bipartisanship and what a
tremendous honor it is to work on this
committee
mr chairman at 601 pm on january 6th
after he spent hours watching a violent
mob besiege attack and invade our
capital
donald trump tweeted
but he did not condemn the attack
instead he justified it right
these are the things and
it happened he said when a sacred
landslide election victory is so
unceremoniously and viciously stripped
away from great patriots who've been
badly and unfairly treated for so long
as you will see in the hearings to come
president trump believed his supporters
at the capitol and i quote
were doing what they should be doing
this is what he told his staff as they
pleaded with him to call off the mob to
instruct his supporters to leave
over a series of hearings in the coming
weeks you will hear testimony live and
on video
from more than half a dozen former white
house staff in the trump administration
all of whom were in the west wing of the
white house on january 6th
you will hear testimony that quote the
president did not really want to put
anything out
calling off the riot obviously or asking
his supporters to leave of course you
will hear that president trump was
yelling and quote really angry at
advisors who told him he needed to be
doing something more
and aware of the rioters chance to hang
mike pence the president responded with
this sentiment quote
maybe our supporters have the right idea
wow mike pence quote deserves it oh my
god that kid you'll hear evidence that
president trump refused for hours to do
what his staff his family and many of
his other advisors begged him to do
immediately instruct his supporters to
stand down and evacuate the capitol
tonight
you will see never before seen footage
of the brutal attack on our capitol
an attack that unfolded while a few
blocks away president trump
sat watching television in the dining
room next to the oval office
you will hear audio from the brave
police officers
battling for their lives and ours
fighting to defend our democracy
against a violent mob donald trump
refused to call off wow
tonight and in the weeks to come
you will see evidence of what motivated
this violence including directly from
those who participated in this attack
you will see video of them explaining
what caused them to do it you will see
their posts on social media we will show
you what they have said in federal court
on this point there is no room for
debate
those who invaded our capital and
battled law enforcement for hours were
motivated by what president trump had
told them
that the election was stolen
and that he was the rightful president
one of the weddings president trump
summoned the mob assembled the mob and
lit the flame of this attack
you will also hear about plots to commit
seditious conspiracy on january 6.
correct a crime defined in our laws as
conspiring to overthrow put down or
destroy by force the government of the
united states
or to oppose by force the authority
thereof
multiple members of two groups the oath
keepers and the proud boys have been
charged with this crime for their
involvement in the events leading up to
and on january 6th accurate some have
pled guilty true the attack on our
capital was not a spontaneous riot
intelligence available before january 6
identified plans to quote invade the
capital occupy the capital and take
other steps to halt congress's count of
electoral votes that day
in our hearings to come we will identify
elements of those plans and we will show
specifically how a group of proud boys
led a mob into the capitol building on
january 6.
tonight i am going to describe for you
some of what our committee has learned
and highlight initial findings you will
see this month in our hearings
as you hear this
all americans should keep in fact in
mind this fact
on the morning of january 6th
president donald trump's intention was
to remain president of the united states
despite the lawful outcome of the 2020
election
and in violation of his constitutional
obligation to relinquish power
over multiple months donald trump
oversaw
and coordinated a sophisticated
seven-part plan to overturn the
presidential election and prevent the
transfer of presidential power
in our hearings you will see evidence of
each element of this plan
elements in our second hearing you will
see that donald trump and his advisers
knew
that he had in fact lost the election
but despite this president trump engaged
in a massive effort to spread false and
fraudulent information
to convince huge portions of the u.s
population that fraud had stolen the
election from him
this was not true
jason miller was a senior trump campaign
spokesman
in this clip
miller describes a call between the
trump campaign's internal data expert
and president trump a few days after the
2020 election
i was in the oval office
um
and
at some point in the conversation matt
oskowski who is the lead data person was
brought on
and
i remember he delivered to the president
pretty blunt terms
that he was going to lose
and that was based uh mr miller on madd
and the data team's assessment of the
sort of county by county state by state
results as reported correct
alex cannon was one of president trump's
campaign lawyers he previously worked
for the trump organization
one of his responsibilities was to
assess allegations of election fraud in
november 2020
here is one sample of his testimony
discussing what he told white house
chief of staff mark meadows
i remember
a call all
with
mr meadows
where mr meadows was asking me
what i was finding and if i was finding
anything
and i remember sharing with him that
we weren't finding anything
that would be
sufficient to um
change the results in any of the key
states there was no fraud when was that
conversation
probably in november
mid to late november i think it was
before my child was born
and what was mr meadow's reaction to
that information
i believe the words he used were so
there's no there there
they all knew it there's no there there
now the trump campaign meadows after
that kept spreading that there was all
these problems he explained that all of
the fraud allegations
and the campaign's other election
arguments taken together
and viewed in the best possible light
for president trump could
still not change the outcome of the
election
president trump's attorney general bill
barr also told donald trump his election
claims were wrong
repeatedly
told the president in no uncertain terms
that
i did not see evidence of fraud
and you know that would have affected
the outcome of the election
and frankly a year and a half later i
haven't seen anything to to change my
mind on that
fraud attorney general barr also told
president trump that his allegations
about dominion voting machines were
groundless wow
absolutely zero basis for the
allegations
but they were made in such a sensational
way
that they obviously were influencing a
lot of people
members of the public
that there was this systemic
corruption in the system and that their
votes didn't count and that these
machines controlled by somebody else
were actually determining it which was
complete nonsense
and it was being laid out there and i
told them that it was that it was uh
crazy stuff and they were wasting their
time on that
and uh was doing a great grave
disservice to the country wow
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines dominion
allegations in public at least a dozen
more times even after his attorney
general told him they were quote
complete nonsense
and after barr's resignation on december
23rd the acting attorney general who
replaced him jeff rosen and the acting
deputy richard donahue told president
trump over and over again that the
evidence did not support allegations he
was making in public
many of president trump's white house
staff also recognized that the evidence
did not support the claims president
trump was making
this is the president's daughter
commenting on bill barr's statement that
the department found no fraud sufficient
to overturn the election we expected
how did that affect your perspective
about the election when attorney general
barr made that statement
it affected my perspective um i respect
attorney general barr
um
so i
accepted what he said was saying wow
as you will hear on monday the president
had every right to litigate ivanka's
essentially a witness against her dad
here lost more than 60 cases in state
and federal courts
the president's claims in the election
cases were so frivolous and unsupported
that the president's lead lawyer rudy
giuliani not only lost the lawsuits his
license to practice law was suspended
correct here's what the court said of mr
giuliani
communicated demonstrably false and
misleading statements to courts
lawmakers and the public at large in his
capacity as lawyer for former president
donald j trump and the trump campaign in
connection with trump's failed effort at
re-election in 2020
as you will see in great detail in our
hearings
president trump ignored the rulings of
our nation's courts
he ignored his own campaign leadership
his white house staff
many republican state officials he
ignored the department of justice and
the department of homeland security
president trump invested millions of
dollars of camping funds purposely
spreading false information
running ads he knew were false
and convincing millions of americans
that the election was corrupt and that
he was the true president
as you will see this misinformation
campaign provoked the violence on
january 6th
in our third hearing you will see
that president trump corruptly planned
to replace the attorney general of the
united states
so the u.s justice department would
spread his false stolen election claims
in the days before january 6 president
trump told his top justice department
officials quote
just say the election was corrupt and
leave the rest to me and the republican
congressman
senior justice department officials
men he had appointed
told him they could not do that because
it was not true
so president trump decided to replace
them
he offered jeff clark an environmental
lawyer at the justice department the job
of acting attorney general
president trump wanted mr clark to take
a number of steps
including sending this letter to georgia
and five other states
saying the u.s department of justice had
quote
identified significant concerns that may
have impacted the outcome of the
election
this letter is a lie
the department of justice had in fact
repeatedly told president trump exactly
the opposite that they had investigated
his stolen election allegations and
found no credible fraud that could
impact the outcome of the election
this letter and others like it would
have urged multiple states
to withdraw their official and lawful
electoral votes for biden
acting deputy attorney general richard
donahue described jeff clark's letter
this way quote
this would be a grave step for the
department to take and could have
tremendous constitutional political and
social ramifications for this country
the committee agrees with mr donohue's
assessment
had clarke assumed the role of attorney
general in the days before january 6 and
issued these letters the ramifications
could indeed have been grave
mr donahue also said this about clark's
plan
and i recall toward the end saying what
you're proposing is nothing less than
the united states justice department
meddling in the outcome of a
presidential election that's what he
wanted
in our hearings you will hear firsthand
how the senior leadership of the
department of justice threatened to
resign
how the white house counsel threatened
to resign and how they confronted donald
trump and jeff clark in the oval office
the men involved including acting
attorney general jeff rosen and acting
deputy attorney general richard donahue
were appointed by president trump these
men honored their oaths of office they
did their duty and you will hear from
them in our hearings
by contrast jeff clark has invoked his
fifth amendment privilege against
self-incrimination and refused to
testify
representative scott perry who is also
involved in trying to get clark
appointed as attorney general has
refused to testify here
as you will see
representative perry contacted the white
house in the weeks after january 6
to seek a presidential pardon
multiple other republican congressmen
also sought presidential pardons for
their roles in attempting to overturn
the 2020 election
in our fourth hearing we will focus on
president trump's efforts to pressure
vice president mike pence to refuse to
count electoral votes on january 6th
vice president pence has spoken publicly
about this
but president trump is wrong
i had no right to overturn the election
the presidency belongs to the american
people and the american people alone
and frankly there is no idea more on
america
than the notion that any one person
could choose the american president
what president trump demanded that mike
pence do wasn't just wrong it was
illegal and it was unconstitutional
you will hear this in great detail from
the vice president's former general
counsel wow witnesses in these hearings
will explain how the former vice
president and his staff informed
president trump over and over again that
what he was pressuring mike pence to do
was illegal
as you will hear president trump engaged
in a relentless effort to pressure pence
both in private and in public
you will see the evidence of that
pressure from multiple witnesses live
and on video
vice president pence demonstrated his
loyalty to donald trump consistently
over four years
but he knew that he had a higher duty to
the united states constitution
this is testimony from the vice
president's chief of staff oh this
should be good
so i think the vice president was proud
of his four years of service and he felt
like how much had been accomplished in
those four years and i think he was
proud to have stood beside the president
for all that had been done but i think
he ultimately knew that his fidelity the
constitution was his first and foremost
oath what a good guy
and that's that's what he articulated
publicly and i think that that's what he
felt
his fidelity to the constitution was
more important than his fidelity to
president trump and his device he took
yes
you'll also hear about a lawyer named
john eastman yes mr eastman was deeply
involved in president trump's plans
you'll hear from former 4th circuit
federal judge michael luedig a highly
respected leading conservative judge
john eastman clerked for judge ludig
judge ludig provided counsel to the vice
president's team in the days before
january 6th
the judge will explain how eastman quote
was wrong at every turn
and you will see the email exchanges
between eastman and the vice president's
council as the violent attack on
congress was underway
mr jacob said this to me mr eastman
thanks to your we are under
siege
you will also see evidence that john
eastman did not actually believe the
legal position he was taking in fact a
month before the 2020 election eastman
took exactly the opposite view on the
same legal issues
in the course of the select committee's
work to obtain information from mr
eastman we have had occasion to present
evidence to a federal judge
the judge evaluated the facts and he
reached the conclusion that president
trump's efforts to pressure vice
president pence to act illegally by
refusing to count electoral votes
likely violated two federal criminal
statutes at least and the judge also
said this
if dr eastman and president trump's plan
had worked it would have permanently
ended the peaceful transition of power
undermining american democracy and the
constitution
if the country does not commit to
investigating and pursuing
accountability for those responsible the
court fears january 6 will repeat itself
every american should read what this
federal judge has written
the same judge judge carter issued
another decision on tuesday night just
this week
indicating that john eastman and other
trump lawyers knew that their legal
arguments had no real chance of success
in court of course they relied on those
arguments anyway to try to quote
overturn a democratic election
and you will hear that while congress
was under attack on january 6 and the
hours following the violence the trump
legal team in the willard hotel war room
continued to work to halt the count of
electoral votes
in our fifth hearing you will see
evidence that president trump corruptly
pressured state legislators and election
officials to change election results
you will hear additional details about
president trump's call to georgia
officials urging them to quote find 11
780 votes
votes that did not exist
and his efforts to get states to rescind
certified electoral slates without
factual basis and contrary to law
you will hear new details about the
trump campaign and other trump
associates efforts to instruct
republican officials in multiple states
to create intentionally false electoral
slates and transmit those slates to
congress to the vice president and
what's fascinating is
we covered all of these things but the
way they're dividing these up into these
seven different pieces
it was such a widespread and deep
running plan as you will hear
how president trump summoned a violent
mob and directed them illegally to march
on the united states capitol
while the violence was underway
president trump failed to take immediate
action to stop the violence and instruct
his supporters to leave the capitol
as we present these initial findings
keep two points in mind
first
our investigation is still ongoing so
what we make public here will not be the
complete set of information we will
ultimately disclose
and second the department of justice is
currently working with cooperating
witnesses
and has disclosed to date only some of
the information it is identified from
encrypted communications and other
sources
on december 18 2020
a group including general michael flynn
sydney powell rudy giuliani and others
visited the white house true they stayed
late into the evening
we know that the group discussed a
number of dramatic steps
including having the military seize
voting machines and potentially rerun
elections yep
you will also hear that president trump
met with that group alone for a period
of time before white house lawyers and
other staff discovered the group was
there and rushed to intervene
a little more than an hour after ms
powell mr giuliani general flynn and the
others finally left the white house
president trump sent the tweet on the
screen now
telling people to come to washington on
january 6th yep be there he instructed
them
will be wild
as you will see this was a pivotal
moment this tweet
initiated a chain of events the tweet
led to the planning for what occurred on
january 6th including by the proud boys
who ultimately led the invasion of the
capitol and the violence on that day
the indictment of a group of proud boys
alleges that they planned
to oppose by force the authority of the
government of the united states
and according to the department of
justice
on january 6 2021 the defendants
directed mobilized and led members of
the crowd onto the capitol grounds and
into the capitol
leading to the dismantling of metal
barricades the destruction of property
the breaching of the capitol building
and the assaults on law enforcement
although certain former trump officials
have argued that they did not anticipate
violence on january 6th the evidence
suggests otherwise
as you will see in our hearings the
white house was receiving specific
reports in the days leading up to
january 6th including during president
trump's ellipse rally
indicating that elements in the crowd
were preparing for violence at the
capitol
and on the evening of january 5th the
president's close advisor steve bannon
said this on his podcast
we covered this
all hell is going to break loose
tomorrow
just understand this all hell is going
to break loose tomorrow oh but i mean
part of our investigation we will
present information about what the white
house and other intelligence agencies
knew
and why the capital was not better
prepared
but we will not lose sight of the fact
that the capitol police did not cause
the crowd to attack
and we will not blame the violence that
day
violence provoked by donald trump on the
officers who bravely defended all of us
in our final hearing you will hear a
moment by moment account of the
hours-long attack from more than half a
dozen white house staff both live in the
hearing room and via videotape testimony
there's no doubt that president trump
was well aware of the violence as it
developed
white house staff urged president trump
to intervene and call off the mob
here is a document written while the
attack was underway by a member of the
white house staff
advising what the president needed to
say
quote anyone who entered the capitol
without proper authority should leave
immediately
this is exactly what his supporters on
capitol hill and nationwide were urging
the president to do
you will hear that leaders on capitol
hill begged the president for help
including republican leader mccarthy who
was quote scared
and called multiple members of president
trump's family after he could not
persuade the president himself
not only did president trump refuse to
tell the mob to leave the capitol
he placed no call to any element of the
united states government to instruct
that the capital be defended
he did not call his secretary of defense
on january 6th he did not talk to his
attorney general he did not talk to the
department of homeland security
president trump gave no order to deploy
the national guard that day
and he made no effort to work with the
department of justice to coordinate and
displa and deploy law enforcement assets
but vice president pence did each of
those things
for example
here is what general milley the chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff testified
to this committee
so with two or three calls with vice
presidents he was very animated and he
issued very explicit
uh
very
direct unambiguous orders
there was no question about that and he
was and and i can get to the exact
quotes i guess from some of our records
somewhere but he was very animated very
direct
very firm
and to secretary miller get the military
on it get the guard down here put down
this
situation
et cetera
by contrast here is general milly's
description of his conversation with
president trump's chief of staff mark
meadows on january 6th
he said um
we have we have to kill the narrative
that the vice president is making
all the decisions
uh we need to establish
the narrative
that
um
you know that the president is still in
charge and that
things are steady or stable or what's
happening
i immediately interpret that as politics
politics politics
red flag for me personally no action but
i remember
wow
was that woke general milly is how the
day played out inside the white house
how multiple white house staff resigned
and discussed and how president trump
would not ask his supporters to leave
the capitol
it was only after multiple hours of
violence that president trump finally
released a video
instructing the riotous mob to leave
and as he did so he said to them quote
we love you play the video and you're
very special
you will also hear that in the immediate
aftermath of january 6th members of the
president's family white house staff
and others
tried to step in to stabilize the
situation quote to land the plane before
the presidential transition on january
20th
you will hear about members of the trump
cabinet discussing the possibility of
invoking the 25th amendment
and replacing the president of the
united states big time stuff multiple
members of president trump's own cabinet
resigned immediately after january 6th
one member of the cabinet suggested that
the remaining cabinet officers needed to
take a more active role in running the
white house and the administration
but most emblematic of those days is
this exchange of texts between sean
hannity and former president
uh trump's press secretary kaylee
mcanini here we go sean hannity wrote in
part
key now
no more crazy people
no more stolen election talk
yes impeachment and 25th amendment are
real
many people will quit
ms mcinnani responded in part love that
that's the playbook
the white house staff knew
that president trump was willing to
entertain and use conspiracy theories to
achieve his ends of course they knew the
president needed to be cut off from all
of those who had encouraged him now i
know a lot of that material to i know my
audience you guys know about all this
material because i've been talking about
it but understand to many of the people
watching this they are they have no idea
these text messages exist important
facts for congress and the american
people to understand fully
when a president fails to take the steps
necessary to preserve our union or worse
causes a constitutional crisis
we're at a moment of maximum danger for
our republic
some in the white house took responsible
steps to try to prevent january 6th
others egged the president on
others yes fair many of the people that
need to see this also aren't watching
but some of them are this case the white
house counsel was so concerned about
potentially lawless activity that he
threatened to resign multiple times
that is exceedingly rare and exceedingly
serious
it requires immediate attention
especially when the entire team
threatens to resign
however in the trump white house it was
not exceedingly rare and it was not
treated seriously
this is a clip of jared kushner oh here
we go addressing multiple threats by
white house counsel pat sipoloni and his
team of lawyers to resign in the weeks
before january 6th
jared uh are you aware of um instances
where uh pat cipolloni threatened to
resign i i kind of like i said my
interest at that time was on trying to
get as many pardons done uh and i know
that you know he was always
to him and the team were always saying
oh we're going to resign we're not going
to be here if this happens if that
happens so
i kind of took it up to just be whining
to be honest with you
whining
there's a reason why people serving in
our government take an oath to the
constitution
as our founding fathers recognize
democracy is fragile
there were people whining wow you want
to follow the constitution
in our country we don't swear an oath to
an individual or a political party we
take our oath to defend the united
states constitution
and that oath must mean something
tonight i say this to my republican
colleagues who are defending the
indefensible
there will come a day when donald trump
is gone
your dishonor will remain wow
finally shots by all of our fellow
americans as you watch our hearings over
the coming weeks please remember what's
at stake
remember the men and women who have
fought and died so that we can live
under the rule of law not the rule of
men
i ask you to think of the scene in our
capital rotunda on the night of january
6th
there in a sacred space in our
constitutional republic
the place where our presidents lie in
state
watched over by statues of washington
and jefferson lincoln and grant
eisenhower ford and reagan
against every wall that night encircling
the room there were swat teams
men and women in tactical gear with long
guns
deployed inside our capitol building
there in the rotunda these brave men and
women rested beneath paintings depicting
the earliest scenes of our republic
including one painted in 1824
depicting george washington resigning
his commission
voluntarily relinquishing power
handing control of the continental army
back to congress
with this noble act washington set the
indispensable example of the peaceful
transfer of power
what president reagan called nothing
less than a miracle
the sacred obligation to defend this
peaceful transfer of power
has been honored by every american
president
except one
as americans we all have a duty to
ensure that what happened on january 6th
never happens again
to set aside partisan battles
to stand together to perpetuate and
preserve our great republic
thank you mr
chairman wow
as we provide answers to american people
about january 6th
it's important that we remember exactly
what took place
that this was no tourist visit to the
capitol
most of the footage
we are about to play has never been seen
oh man the select committee obtained it
as a part of our investigation
this isn't easy to watch
i want to warn everyone
that this video includes violence and
strong language
without objection my understanding is
there's no gore and that this is fine
for the platforms we're on balance of
january 6th
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah it's for awareness be advised
there's probably about 300
proud boys they're marching eastbound
and this 400 block of um kind of
independence actually on the mall
towards the united capitol
i am not allowed to say what's going to
happen today
because everyone's just going to have to
watch for themselves ominous but
it's going to happen
something's going to happen
[Music]
11 22. okay we were live then
you can tell how unorganized this is
can't you guys
20 bucks a picture
of the moment he's gonna do the right
thing i hope so
i hope so
because if mike pence does the right
thing
we win the election all vice president
pence has to do is send it back to the
states to recertify
and we become president and you are the
happiest doesn't exist
it doesn't exist pence is going to have
to come through for us and if he doesn't
that will be a sad day for our country
because you'll never
take back our country with weakness you
have to show strength
[Applause]
[Music]
stepping off here
there's a crowd search heading east
mike pence i hope you're gonna stand up
for the good of our constitution and for
the good it's somehow even crazier
watching it now after the fact
i will tell you right now
[Music]
[Applause]
it's antifa everywhere
i was about to stop streaming at one and
ag and at 12 54 i remember it was sort
of like are they
are they are they breaching what are
they in the capitol
priority we just had
preach the fun
we need backups
[Applause]
[Music]
it's quite literally a mob
is that guy wearing kevlar and has a bat
madam speaker
the vice president and the united states
senate
[Applause]
warning but i'm trying to get compliance
but this is now effectively a riot
it's effectively a riot riot
[Applause]
whoops oh my god
guys i'm sorry about that let's go back
to the live i'm sorry
[Applause]
so they're trying to hold up
oh
[Applause]
i remember that
yep
we saw this
[Applause]
reach from live capitol to the upper
level
jack these guys they're requesting
additional resources on the east side as
they've broken into that window and
they're trying to kick it in
here are the patriots bravely trying to
overturn the results with
violence didn't have the courage to do
what should have been done to protect
our country and our constitution giving
states a chance to certify a corrected
set of facts
not the fraudulent or inaccurate ones
which they were asked to previously
certify
u.s demands
[Applause]
[Music]
hang mike pence
[Applause]
remember when marjorie taylor green said
we thought it was antifa in blm
[Applause]
we can't hold this we're going to get
too many people look at this
bandages
[Applause]
remember guys that the rioters are
patriots and they back the blue and they
support the police
you guys remember all that stuff members
they're all walking over now through the
tunnels
[Applause]
we
okay
[Applause]
these are the people against uh
defunding or even reforming the police
remember that
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
chanting nancy
[Music]
[Applause]
looks like someone was was pepper
spraying officers there as well
[Applause]
h208 with four members the doors
barricade there's people wanted there's
always outside we have no way out
a vast officer is still remaining on the
house floor and on the third floor to
use the subway themselves it's time to
evacuate so we can secure the members on
the other side of coffee
[Applause]
[Music]
right at a certain point they're saying
get all the members of the house out of
there
one more time
[Applause]
and whatever it takes i'll lay my life
down if it takes there you go absolutely
that's why we showed up today
[Applause]
[Music]
was that an officer down there
[Applause]
now we're getting to the end
they support the police yeah
look at that
i mean we're dealing with savages here
right
[Applause]
[Music]
they were peaceful people these were
great people
the crowd was unbelievable and i
mentioned the word love the love
the love in the air i've never seen
anything like it
this is normal tourism i behaved like
this at the fontana di trevi in rome
when i went yeah
pursuant to the order of the committee
of tonight
the chair declares the committee in
recess
for a period of approximately 10 minutes
wow
a 10-minute break we are an hour into
the first of six
of these january 6 committee hearings
it's incredible to relive a whole bunch
of it to be quite frankly
it's actually crazier it's actually
crazier in uh in retrospect i don't even
know
i mean we you know many of us lived it
on the day of
um
it's nauseating that's exactly right
that's exactly right
uh
let's see
what is on people's minds by the way
i can't even come close to thanking
everybody who has been signing up thank
you to everyone today's coupon code not
surprisingly is indict
i am here because this is so important
in the middle of my paternity leave
because this is of utmost importance
i don't think i have to explain the
meaning of today's coupon code indict
i refuse to explain it we all understand
the meaning of the coupon code indict
and you can use that code
at joinpackman.com
as so many people have indict is the
code
and it's the word of the day quite
frankly
um
david we will never forget watching this
live with you and your audience sadly an
unforgettable moment
in history these are just repeats guys
we already we already watched all of
this they are taking just a brief
10-minute break
and then uh
they are going to be back
we are not missing any of it everybody
relax everything's fine
savages
david sir remember the power
of dehumanizing language oh guys
we're we're using the language about
yeah that that's
i i think that that's uh
that has to be a bad faith comment
such a sad day in american history
savages oh there's nurse betty you know
nurse betty and progressive beard should
talk to each other
i agree with you that it looks much
worse now says larry on a lighter note i
just returned from mexico where i tried
mamie mamey for the first time i don't
know what that is i thought you'd
appreciate it mango's so good i'd pay 11
bucks a bag yeah
yeah
uh this is one of the officers
from uh capitol police i forget the
names of the of all the officers who
testified that's that's one of the
officers
david your usual funny incident uh
accent it's pronounced coupon code right
because c-o-u-p is coo so therefore
c-o-u-p-o-n it's not coupon it's kuan
listen thank you to paul wilson
thank you to sarah owen for signing up
at joinpackman.com
um thanks to manny
and beth for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 164. there's
our good friend jamie raskin make sure
to check out my interview with him from
last week
a very strong declarations
watching from australia says andy having
dropped just dropped off my
four-year-old son to go to preschool i
thank god on my way out for the safety
of our country well said
well said
sir i'm in canada i have two young kids
one just four months my wife had 18
months off for both i took a few as well
we couldn't imagine not having the
family time sorry you caught flak
congratulations well thank you jordan
please stop muting the video okay i will
i will
but an unarmed black man gets killed for
a license play
david what do we know about the panic
buttons being disabled can you speak on
that i i really can't
um hold on a second someone using the
term libtards unironically
that's a ban
a lot of banning tonight
happy for your new family david have to
ask boy or girl congrats again oh it'll
all be it'll all come out it's all going
to come out
it's going to come out very soon just
like the audits
mamey
is a mexican fruit i can highly
recommend beautiful
longtime watcher appreciate your
commentary keep on keeping on david well
thank you very much thanks to
paco taco
for the twitch prime subscription
also a big thank you
to
michael drake's michael drake signing up
at joinedpakman.com yeah we have
uh we have gobs of streams coming up we
have the january 6 committee streams
we have the election results streams
we have what else maybe the march for
your life stream i'm not sure about that
we're still figuring it all out
and
our primary source of funding we've lost
youtube before we've lost facebook
before we've lost tvitch before
the primary source of funding that we
have
uh that's as we see congresswoman zoe
lofgren talking to adam schiff and adam
kinzinger and liz cheney
uh is
our website we control it from start to
finish
you can sign up at joinpackman.com i
will thank every single one of you and
you can use the coupon code indict
to call for what we all know needs to
happen we all know it
opening statements were powerful correct
betty
um
what's the live take on truth essential
yeah that's a good question let's see
uh truth social
let's see if trump has dumped in any
comments
on his platform
you guys know about trump's platform
right truth essential yeah
uh no he hasn't posted in 11 hours but
earlier he was posting about the
unselect committee
uh he called them a group of political
thugs
um
very very weaponized messages tomorrow's
host luke beasley i predict i predict
is going to be talking about these
unhinged messages on of course our
favorite social media platform truth
essential right there is no better place
there is really no better place for any
of it
uh so strange to relive all of this with
you well said
thanks to doom cats mr vister
and vicious elm as well as meech mark
for the twitch prime subscriptions thank
you everybody i appreciate that
over on the website memberships are
dumping in david delay
chris missile andrew lloyd paco jacobo
all sending in memberships remember that
you can also now gift memberships if you
have one when you check out just checks
that check this box that says this is a
gift this is the way the check box works
okay
if it's a gift you check it and i have a
list of 450 people waiting for free
memberships if it's not a gift you don't
check it okay please don't email me
asking me how the box works
no emails about the box please
please
i can't take it
plenty of room on that floating wooden
door for both rose and jack
indeed yeah
david competitive races in pennsylvania
for people 7 and 8 and 17th districts
all held by democrats and need the
resources congrats david thanks for the
great coverage thank you ashley
thank you for everything you do thanks
kevin
congrats on the kid david i remember
watching the insurrection live one of
the most sickening days i've witnessed
anyone who supports this truly isn't
american
thanks to flamingo ghost and primo scott
for the twitch prime subscriptions
it's it's in play that we would get to
200 today uh corbin lloyd just signed up
uh
and this is maybe potentially an
offensive name so i'm gonna i'm gonna
skip that
uh bernice ma
varun karnat
and marcus mcgirt all
signing up at jointpakman.com very much
appreciate that
uh let's listen here
they're almost back
looks like they're about ready to come
to order
which we love we love order
a lot of congrats coming in from
different people
what's in the box
since january 6 i can't wear anything
with an american flag says nurse betty
the insurrections stained this for me
david greetings from belgium strange an
18 year old can buy an ar-15 but the
capitol police don't have guns to shoot
at the savages oh the capitol police had
guns they didn't shoot anybody but they
had guns uh well no that's not
technically true there was the one woman
who was killed
so they did shoot one person
a lot of controversy over that indeed
thanks to nancy fielding for the new
membership edgar hernandez welcome
melissa esquibel has signed up on my
website francis du forte steve edwards
new member welcome dave kramer
john stennett
zachary egan is a new member corey
schutz as well and we are back
the committee will
be in order
i want to thank our witnesses for being
with us this evening
to share their firsthand accounts
of that terrible day
i know that some of the witnesses from
our first hearing in the room with us
along with some of the family members
friends and widows
of the officers who lost their lives
as a result of the attack indeed
thank you all for being here for us and
the american people
officer carolyn edwards has been with
the united states capitol police since
on january 6th officer edwards was
assigned to the first responder
unit which serves as the first line of
defense at the capitol complex
she also served as a member of the civil
disturbance unit
a special subset of the uniform division
trained to respond to mass demonstration
events
officer edwards is a graduate of the
university of georgia and currently is
working on a master's degree
in intelligence analysis
from john hopkins university
nick quisted
is an acclaimed filmmaker who credits
include documenting stories
from war zones in afghanistan syria and
iraq
on january 6th mr quikstead was working
on a documentary
about
quote why americans are so divided when
americans have so much in common
end quote
during that day
mr quested interviewed and documented
movements of the people around the
capitol
including the first moments
of the violence against the capitol
police
and the chaos that it ensued
i will now swear in our witnesses the
witnesses will please stand and raise
your right hand
do you swear and affirm on the penalty
of perjury that the testimony you're
about to give is the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so help
you god
let directly reflect the witnesses
answered in the affirmative
without objection the witness's
statement will be included in the record
pursuant to section 5 c8 of house
resolution 503
i recognize myself for questioning
as you saw just a few minutes ago the
proud boys instigated the first breach
of the capital
just before one o'clock p.m
where rioters pushed over barricades
near the peace circle
at the foot of the capitol
our two witnesses tonight were both
there
at the time of that first breach
officer edwards was standing with other
officers behind a line of bike racks
that marked the perimeter of the capitol
grounds
she bravely tried to prevent an angry
crowd from advancing on the capitol
unfortunately
she was overrun and knocked unconscious
as the crowd advanced on the capitol
mrs quikster was a few yards away from
officer edwards taking footage of the
proud boys as part of his work on a
documentary film most of his footage
has never been shown publicly before we
shared it this evening
officer edwards i'd like to start by
asking
if you could tell us why you believe
it's important for you to share your
story this evening with the committee
and the american public
please no boy your microphone
um well thank you mr chairman i really
appreciate it and thank you to the
committee for having me here to testify
um
i was called a lot of things on january
6 2021 in the days thereafter
i was called nancy pelosi's dog
called incompetent
called a hero
and a villain
i was called a traitor to my country
my oath
and my constitution
in actuality i was none of those things
i was an american
standing face to face with other
americans asking myself how many times
many many times how we had gotten here
i had been called names before
but never had my patriotism or duty been
called into question that's what they do
i who got up every day
no matter how early the hour or how late
i got in the night before to put on my
uniform and to protect america's symbol
of democracy
i who spent countless hours in the
baking sun and freezing snow to make
sure that america's elected officials
were able to do their job
i
whose literal blood sweat and tears were
shed that day defending the building
that i spent countless holidays and
weekends working in
i am the proud granddaughter of a marine
that fought in the battle of the chosen
reservoir in the korean war
i think of my papa often in these days
how he was so young and thrown into a
battle he never saw coming
and answered the call at a great
personal cost
how he lived the rest of his days with
bullets and shrapnel in his legs
but never once complained about his
sacrifice
i would like to think that he would be
proud of me
proud of his granddaughter that stood
her ground that day and continued
fighting even though she was wounded
like he did many years ago
i am my grandfather's granddaughter
proud to put on a uniform and serve my
country
they dared to question my honor
they dared to question my loyalty
and they dared to question my duty
i'm a proud american and i will gladly
sacrifice everything to make sure that
the america my grandfather defended is
here for many years to come
thank you
officer edwards your story
and your service is important
and i thank you for being here tonight
ms quiksted
i also like to ask you to introduce
yourself
can you tell us how you found yourself
in washington dc on january 6 2021
good evening
chair and madame vice chair thank you
for the introduction
um as stated in the winter of 2020 i was
working on a documentary as part of that
documentary i filmed several rallies in
washington dc
on december 11th and december the 12th
and i learned there would be a rally on
the mall in on january 6.
so my three colleagues and i came down
to document the rally according to the
permit of the event there was going to
be a rally at the ellipse
we arrived at the
mall
and observed a large contingent of proud
boys marching towards the capital
we filmed them
and almost immediately i was separated
from my colleagues i documented the
crowd turned from protesters to rioters
to insurrectionists i was surprised at
the size of the group the anger and the
profanity
and for anyone who didn't understand how
violent that event was
i
saw it i documented it and i experienced
it
i heard incredibly aggressive chanting
and i shared subsequently shared that
footage with the authorities
i'm here today s
pursuant to a house subpoena thank you
so much
thank you mr quested
the select committee has conducted
extensive investigative work to
understand what led the proud boys and
other rioters to the capitol on january
6.
we've obtained substantial evidence
showing that the president's december
19th tweet
calling his followers to washington d.c
on january 6
energized
individuals from the proud boys and
others extremist groups
i'd like to play a brief video
highlighting some of this evidence
my name is marcus childress and i'm an
investigative counsel for the select
committee to investigate the january 6
attack on the united states capital what
do you want to call them give me your
name give me a white supremacy
stand back and stand by after he made
this comment enrique tyria then chairman
of the proud boys said on parlor
standing by sir
during our investigation we learned that
this comment during the presidential
debate actually led to an increase in
membership from the proud boys would you
say that proud boys numbers increased
after the stand back standby comment
exponentially i'd say
tripled probably with the potential for
a lot more eventually and did you ever
sell any stand back and stand by
merchandise
uh
one of the vendors on my page actually
beat me to it but i wish i would have i
wish i would have made a stand back
standby shirt this guy's got november
19th president trump tweeted about the
january 6 rally and told attendees be
there will be wild
many of the witnesses that we
interviewed were inspired by the
president's call and came to d.c for
january 6. but the extremists they took
it a step further they viewed this tweet
as a call to arms a day later the
department of justice describes how the
proud boys created a chat called the
ministry of self-defense leadership chat
in this chat the proud boys established
a command structure in anticipation of
coming back to dc on january 6. the
department of justice describes mr
tarrio coming into possession of a
document called the 1776 returns which
describes
individuals occupying key buildings
around the united states capital the
oath keepers are another group that the
committee investigated you better get
your ass to d.c folks this saturday
yeah if you don't there's there'll be no
more republic but we're not going to let
that happen it's not even if it's it's
either president trump is encouraged and
bolstered and strengthened
we all know that the fight's coming the
oath keepers began planning to block the
peaceful transfer of power shortly after
november third election and according to
the department of justice stewart rhodes
the oath keeper's leader
said to his followers that we were not
going to get through this without the
civil war in response to the december
19th 2020 tweet by president trump the
oath keepers focused on january 6 in
washington d.c
in response to the tweet one member the
president of the florida chapter put on
social media the president called us to
the capitol he wants us to make it wild
the goal was for the oath keepers to be
called to duty so that they could keep
the president in power although
president trump had just lost the
election the committee learned that the
oath keepers set up quick reaction
forces outside of the city in virginia
where they stored arms the goal of these
quick reaction forces was to be on
standby just in case president trump
invoked the insurrection act did vote
keepers ever provide weapons to members
i'm going to be planning to answer that
and put them in grounds
for uh
and due process crowds in footage
obtained by the body we learned that on
the night of january 5th enrique tario
and stuart rhodes met in a parking
garage in washington d.c there's mutual
respect there
i think we're
we're fighting the same fight and i
think that's what's important
the committee learned that the oath
keepers went into the capitol through
the east doors and two stack formations
the doj alleges that one of the stacks
went into the capitol looking for
speaker pelosi although they never found
her as the attack was unfolding mr tario
took credit and documents obtained by
the department of justice mr tario said
in an encrypted chat made no mistake and
we did this
[Music]
later on that evening mr tario even
posted a video which seemed to resemble
him in front of the capitol with a black
cape and the title of the video was
premonition
the evidence developed by the select
committee and the department of justice
highlights how each group participated
on the attack on the capitol on january
6th in fact the investigation revealed
that it was individuals associated with
the proud boys who instigated the
initial breach at the peace circle at 12
53 p.m
[Applause]
within 10 minutes riders had already
filled the lower west plaza
[Applause]
by two o'clock rioters had reached the
doors on the west and the east plazas
and by 213 rioters had actually broken
through the senate wing door and got
into the capitol building
a series of breaches followed
at 2 25 pm rioters reached the east side
doors
and then right after 2 40 pm riders
breached the east side doors near the
ways and means room
[Applause]
once the rioters infiltrated the capitol
they moved to the crypt
the rotunda
the hallways leading to the house
chambers
and even inside the senate chambers
[Applause]
individuals associated with two violent
extremist groups have been charged with
seditious conspiracy in connection with
the january sixth attack
one is the oath keepers
they are a group of armed
anti-government extremists
the other group is the proud boys they
promote white supremacist beliefs and
have engaged in violence with people
they view as their political enemies
members of both groups have already pled
guilty to crimes associated with the
january sixth attack big crimes mr
question as part of the documentary
you've been filming you gain access to
the proud boys and their leader enrique
tario
your crew filmed them in washington dc
on the evening of january 5th and then
on january 6th
on january 5th the night before the
attack
you were with the head of the proud boys
mr tario in washington dc on the evening
of january 5th and then on january 6th
on january
night before the attack uh you were with
the head and the restaurant for
mr targeting
washington magazines uh
some extra capacity magazines and
uh for the he took responsibility for
the burning of the
uh black lives matter flag that was
stolen from the church
uh
on december the 12th
oh it's on their feed it's on their feet
see when i mute their feet it stops
let's try a different feed
on december the 12th
we
um we were attempting to get an
interview with mr tario
we had no idea of any of the events that
were going to subsequently happen
um
we drove him to pick up his bags from
the property department of the police
which is just south of the mall
we picked up his bags and went to get
some other bags from the phoenix hotel
where we
encountered mr stewart rhodes
from the oath keepers
[Music]
by the time i'd gone to park the car my
colleague was saying who'd got into the
car with mr tario that they had moved to
a
location around the corner the parking
garage of the
hall of legends i believe
and
so we
quickly drove over there we drove down
into the parking garage
and filmed the scene of mr tario and mr
rhodes uh and certain other individuals
in that garage
we then continued to follow mr tario
there was some discussion about where he
was going to go he ended up going
towards a hotel in baltimore and we
conducted an interview with him in the
hotel room
and then we returned to dc for that
night uh in a um and what was
interesting that night actually was that
was the first indication that dc was
much more
um busy than it had been any other time
we'd been here because we couldn't get
into the hotels we wanted to
and we
ended up at a hotel that you know was
not as satisfactory as we would hoped
thank you so the minibar was terrible
what you're saying is you
filmed the meeting between mr tario and
oath keepers leader stuart rose right
indeed
you couldn't hear what was said but
according to the justice department
indictment of mr tario
a participant referenced the capital
now on the morning of january 6th you
learn the proud boys would gather near
the rallies scheduled
to take place near the white house
what time did you meet up with the proud
boys and what was happening when they
met
we met up with the proud boys
somewhere around 10 30 a.m and they were
starting to walk
down the mile uh
in easterly direction towards the
capital
there was a
a large contingent more than i had
expected and i was
confused to a certain extent why we were
walking away from the president's speech
because that's what um
i felt we were there to cover
so at 10 30 a.m
uh that's early in the day that's even
before president trump had started
speaking am i correct yes sir
so how many proud boys would you
estimate were marching together
to the capitol
um a couple of hundred spur at the
moment potentially yeah i say a couple
of hundred proud boys were marching
towards the capital at that point
at the time was the area heavily guarded
no that was um we met i remember we
walked past the we walked down the mall
we walked to the right of the reflecting
pool and then north along the road that
leads to the peace circle and as we were
walking past the peace circle i framed
the proud boys to the right of my shot
with the capital behind
and we see one sole police officer
at the barriers which are subsequently
breached
we then walk up and past a
um tactical unit preparing
and there's you see that in the film
where the man questions their duty and
their honor and you see
maybe a dozen
capital police
putting on their riot gear
so
how would you describe the atmosphere
at that
that time
the atmosphere was it seemed to be much
darker i i make efforts to create
a familiarity between myself and my
subjects to you know make them feel
comfortable
and um
the the atmosphere was much darker than
at this day than than had been in these
other in these other in these other days
and there was also a contingent of proud
boys that i hadn't met before from
arizona who appeared to wear these
orange hats
and had orange armbands
so when the proud boys went back down
the hill to the peace circle
did a larger crowd start together
well no first of all we went round to
the back and down the steps and we took
some photographs on the east side of the
capitol
and then we went for lunch we went for
tuckers
tacos
so mr question you're a journalist
so you are careful to stick to things
that you have observed
but what you've told us
is highly relevant
let me highlight a few key facts that
you and others have provided the
committee
first there was a large group of proud
boys present at the capitol
we know that from multiple sources
you now estimate that there were around
to 300 individuals that you've testified
they weren't there for president trump's
speech
we know this because they left that area
to march toward the capitol before the
speech began true they walked around the
capitol that morning
i'm concerned this allowed them to see
what defenses were in place and where
weaknesses might be
and they decided to launch their attack
at the peace peace circle
which is a front door of the capital
complex
it's the first security perimeter
that those marching from the ellipse
would have to come to as they moved
toward the capitol
the peace circle walk away
was
walkway
was always where the thousands of angry
trump supporters would arrive after
president trump
sent them
from the lips
the proud boys timed their attack to the
moments before the start of the joint
session
in the capitol which is also where
president trump directed the angry mob
quote we fight like hell end quote he
told them before sending them
down pennsylvania avenue right to where
the proud boys gathered and where you
were filming
now central question is whether the
attack on the capitol was coordinated
and planned
there what you witnessed is what a
coordinated and planned effort would
look like it was the culmination of
months long efforts to